you're on your transformation doesn't
mean that I'm in the right I'm in the
same spot with you so okay all right all
right cool
Kanye West storms out on Kim Kardashian
after confronting her about her super
sexy Met Gala look I'm really freaking
out on Sunday night's episode of Keeping
Up with the Kardashians
Kanye surprisingly admits to having an
issue with people gawking at his
gorgeous white horses like I wonder
where is hot hot for who come in here
and say that you're not into a corset
back
we love each other's opinions well maybe
not in this case as Kim was not okay
with the 42 year old rappers concerns
over her choice in wardrobe for fashions
biggest night just went through this
transition where from being a rapper
like looking at all these girls and
looking at my wife like oh my girl needs
to be just like the other girls showing
a body off show initial and that and I
didn't realize that that was affecting
like my soul and my spirit as someone
that's married and loved and the father
of like now would have about to be four
kids
Kim shut that down real quick you built
me up to have be this like sexy person
and confidence and all this stuff just
because you're on a journey and you're
on your transformation doesn't mean that
I'm in the right I'm in the same spot
with you Kim revealed she spent the
eight months leading up to the ball
preparing her Thierry Mugler ensemble
it is taken eight months to get our met
look perfected and I committed to this
so I can't miss it
her husband's admission is a real change
in tune as Yeezys previously been loud
and proud of his lady loves sexy posts
it's extremely important to me he even
said this during Kim's e true Hollywood
story special that premiered on YouTube
last week chemist speaking body language
stand sheet a [ __ ] dictionary
you don't tell me nothing but everything
seems to work out as Kimye and the fam
hit the Met Gala carpet serving major
looks and it was good to go with Kanye
Ken
[Music]
[Applause]